we talk about weak men this is what's
scariest about this entire agenda
they're trying to purport because their
ideas like the feminist idea and like
the mainstream idea and like Logan
Paul's ideas all their ideals is if we
weaken men then if they become weak
enough they'll no longer be a threat and
I argue that point absolutely I think
the most dangerous men on Earth are the
weak men I think inside of every single
man who are born with a fire inside of
us that we do not control can destroy
ourselves and other people and if you
look at men who have no emotional
control because that's what they're
trying to teach us to have they're
saying listen you're a man you're
allowed to just cry all the time and
have no emotional control no stoicism
just being react to your emotions you
know what happens when you tell men to
just react to their emotions
anger you have school shootings you have
rape you have violence that's what
happens when you tell men to have no
emotional control these School shooters
are kids with no emotional control
rapists are men with no emotional
control violence you see on the street
are met with no emotion control telling
men to not be stoic is going to create a
breed of violent young men who have no
emotional control can't control their
emotions